to present the Oscar for Best Supporting
Actress is a fellow who began to develop
his own acting career while still a very
young man and a string of credits later
he's still developing his skills I don't
know it must be something in the water
out here because he's still a very young
man ladies and gentlemen mr. Ryan O'Neal
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I was very pleased to be asked
to deal with this particular category
tonight it was a number of years ago
when my own daughter came into the
business that I became quite familiar
with supporting actresses 1984 showed us
once again what a wealth of gifted women
filmmakers can call upon while only five
are the finalists they represent scores
more who enhance any film in which they
appear those five are Peggy Ashcroft in
a Passage to India
Glenn Close in the natural
[Applause]
lindsay crouse in places in the heart
[Applause]
Christine Lahti and swing shift
[Applause]
Geraldine page in the Pope of Greenwich
[Applause]
and the winner is the winner is Peggy
Ashcroft in the passage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I think you must know how infinitely
honored I feel to have the privilege of
accepting this Oscar for my dear friend
Peggy Ashcroft I know it would have been
her dearest wish to be here with you all
on this incredibly happy joyous occasion
for her but I also know you understand
the circumstances which prevented it I
personally would just like to say that I
think it is so marvelous that after an
illustrious career in the theatre for so
many years Peggy should at last be
visible to all those millions of
moviegoers who are have and will
continue to enjoy her consummate
artistry her delicacy and beauty that we
should be able to share that all over
the world with her in the movies is an
enormous coup for all of us thank you